Hi Michael!
>> Hey Charles! How's it going?
>> It's going pretty well. How's it going with you?
>> It is a beautiful fall day here in Providence Rhode Island.
>> Oh that's right it's fall, when you are.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, I think, that's right.
>> So, what we're going to do today, Michael.
If you will indulge me. Is ,we're going to
talk about a different class of ,uh, learning
algorithms and approaches than we've been talking about before.
>> So now the other ones were low class, this is going to
be high class?
>> Exactly. And we call them instance based learning. Which
sounds very hoity toity and high voluting. Don't you agree?
>> Yeah, sure, why not?
>> [LAUGH]
>> It sounds like it maybe has good posture.
>> It does, in fact, have good posture.
>> Well let's, let's learn about it. I'm, I'm, I'm intrigued.
>> Yeah, so I think that ,uh, what we're going to
end up talking about to day is kind of interesting, I
hope. But it's sort of different, and what I'm hoping is
through this discussion Is that, we will be able to reveal
some of the unspoken assumptions that we've been making so far, okay?
>> Unspoken assumptions, it sounds, yeah, okay, that sounds
like we should get to the bottom of that.
>> Yes, so let's do that. So, just to remind you of what we have
been doing in the ,um, past, this is what was going on with all of
our little supervised learning tasks, right. We
were given a bunch of training data ,labeled
here as you know, x, y One, xy two, xy three, dot, dot, dot, xy zen.
And ,uh, we would then learn some function.
So, for example, if we have a bunch of
points in a plane, we might learn a
line to represent them, which is what this little
blue line is. And what was happening here is we take all this data. We come up
with some function that represents the data. And
then we would throw the data away effectively, right?
>> Okay. Yeah, so like, black is the input here and then
the two blue things are what get derived by the learning algorithm.
>> Right. And then in
the future when we get some data point, let's
call it x, we would pass it through this function
whatever it is. In this case, probably line. And
that would, be how we would determine answers going forward.
>> Yeah. That's, that's what we've been talking about.
>> Right. And in particular without reference
to the original data. So. I want
to propose an alternative and the alternative is basically going to not do this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So let me give you a, let me, let me tell u exactly what I mean by that.